wahhhh drew may be tiny but it's safe
and for her that's the most important
thing the Syrian woman has been living
here in Bremen for a few weeks now
waiting for her application for asylum
to be processed in the meantime she's
been busy trying to learn German it is
one of the most difficult languages so
this is what I heard but I'm trying they
told me since I know English very good
it will be easier for me than the others
to learn Deutsch what left because she
feared the life of her four-year-old
daughter now she's going to a German
kindergarten why lost her husband in the
Civil War he was shot dead a year ago
since my husband was killed in Damascus
I start have really like I really panic
regarding my daughter I don't want to
lose her and I don't want to maybe I
will die and she will stay alone it bad
feeling started to come to my mind so I
said okay since I got a visa this is a
good sign for me that I have to leave
Lara Hinata Alena wad was one of the
lucky ones
she got a visa others here fled under
very perilous circumstances and are glad
to have survived the war and the journey
this plane has brought more refugees to
Germany the first contingent of 5000
Syrians that the German government has
agreed to take after three and a half
hour flight from Beirut the Syrians are
greeted by politicians and the media
some have relatives in Germany and are
planning to join them they're relieved
to have escaped the Civil War it's an
indescribable feeling being surrounded
by the media and being able to express
myself freely
this is the children appear to be
holding up well despite what they have
experienced and the abrupt change of
scene just over half the new arrivals
are young people the refugees that
Germany has accepted are regarded as
particularly vulnerable others all the
best in Germany welcomed Germany's
acceptance of 5,000 refugees was
intended to be a generous gesture but in
the face of the large number of refugees
it seems negligible a cause for debate
while it is important and a good thing
that Germany is taking in five thousand
refugees it is important to take in more
if we really want to provide effective
help and we can do that I presume it
will also happen Germany's Interior
Minister believes far more refugees will
land up in Germany anyway in quiet other
channels he wants other European
countries to accept their share she
belted that off I will be pushing for a
European refugee conference to be held
as soon as possible because I think it's
necessary for us to see the Syrian
refugee problem as a European problem
and regarded as a task for the EU
because I'm about Bonnyman the Green
Party says that the German government
shouldn't try to pass on responsibility
to the EU they want to offer asylum to
50,000 Syrians but that requires careful
planning my kindness you know you can
work together with Europe but you can't
retreat to a European position because
Europe's position will always be
strongly influenced by Germany's lead by
what Germany suggests and what Germany
does torch length marked for walid what
happens next in Syria is very important
he'd prefer to return to Syria the young
doctor feels disoriented in Germany but
he's making cautious plans to stay
nonetheless he's hoping that he can work
here
a fishing I don't have any firm plans
but maybe I can work here I'm still
waiting but I hope that things will
improve in Syria at some point and I can
return local residents have been helping
make the Syrian refugees feel more at
home one woman has invited the women to
visit a concert with her she's hoping
this will lead to more contact
stinkies come on nine-cent what it's
been legal hangar fees and I was a
teacher I don't know quite a few refugee
families lived and I know how difficult
it is to find ones bearing here
and I thought I could do something to
help the table football and tennis
tables were also donated by the
neighbors it's making the waiting a
little bit easier most of the people
have little else to do except wait for
their asylum application to be processed
and for peace in Syria